okay so after going through and
reworking my schedule trying to get it
all sorted out try to get everything
organized
god/man the biggest problem I have is
there's so many things I want to cover
and there's just not enough days to
cover them that's the biggest problem
otherwise I'd be doing like different
videos every single day and it just it
gets confusing and crazy but Green
Lantern and like really because of Geoff
Johns run because of how big it is it's
going to be one of those things that we
just kind of do where we have room to
put it and we'll just do it on a classic
DC day and then you know once like
Justice League when the movie comes out
will actually put green lantern on hole
to cover new 52 Justice League and then
come back to Green Lantern again but
what this story does really this this
sort of eye on story is it a lot of ways
it's self-contained I mean really it's
not technically part of the greater
green lantern story but it does give us
some pretty important things with
regards to Kyle waiter and really kind
of elevates him above all the other
Green Lantern's making him somebody a
pretty of a pretty high level of
significance in relation to every other
Green Lantern ever and the subsidy holds
a special place now this will also
become important once we get to the idea
of Kyle Rayner becoming the white
lantern and all those different kinds of
things so again it's really kind of an
important bit here but what this does is
it actually deals initially with the
idea of Kyle Rayner is losing his mind
Kyle Rayner going crazy and actually
attacking a few of the other Green
Lantern's now the reason why this
matters is remember we have our video
where we talk about like the power of
the star heart and again where you'll
find that down in the description but it
basically means that at this moment
right now Kyle laner wields two sources
of power he reeled wields the star heart
which is basically all this magical
energy from another universe as well as
the traditional Green Lantern powers
that are given to him by virtue of a
Green Lantern ring and so the cool thing
about this is that when he doesn't
necessarily reel the ring per se he does
have this insane source of energy about
him and so again it makes things pretty
interesting in terms of how he functions
and in terms of what he does because
he's basically got two sets of powers
combined into one now the reason why
this happens and what seems to be going
on with Kyle Rayner in terms of him
being insane is that he'll black out
he'll basically go to these instances
where he just sort of lashes out he'll
lose his temper he'll attack people and
then he'll black out and wake up
somewhere else in this instance
following this attack on these other
members of the Green Lantern's he simply
wakes up back at home where he meets up
with a guy by the name of Schuler I
think it is but it's really just him
just kind of learning how to be a better
artist remember being an artist as part
of Kyle Rayner forever
for now the reason why this matters and
the reason why this part of the story is
being told is because for a lot of
people keep in mind Geoff Johns run on
Green Lantern was their introduction to
Green Lantern and so really like Ron
Marz Jeff John these guys they could not
come along and basically just throw Cara
Lena in there without giving any
explanation of who he is or what he's
about now he does make small references
so things like his past you know
relationships but that could the the I
guess the history has various women have
always been pretty much unsuccessful in
the sense but for the most part they've
all died this really comes by way of the
fact of a girl who's basically moved in
on the property where you know these
various artists reside and she doesn't
say anything she doesn't speech doesn't
address anybody and when the question is
asked by Kaui Waner who this girl is of
course surely basically says look she
doesn't talk but for him he thinks back
you know to his first major girlfriend
who was killed by major force I think it
was been stuffed into a fridge I mean
there's all these different instances in
his character's history where his
relationships with women just never
really work out they usually I'll end up
dying but in terms of Kyle Rayner
himself and what he means the first
indication of this comes from the
guardians of the universe who are
basically watching all this unfold now
keep in mind in the green lantern
landscape the guardians are very
cloak-and-dagger they do not tell the
Green Lantern's anything unless they
need to know the Guardians keep a lot of
secrets to themselves now this creates
some measure of distrust among the Green
Lantern's especially with Hal Jordan who
doesn't view them as necessarily
trustworthy but views them as necessary
in a sense that maybe they're holding
that information because people don't
need to know but again it creates kind
of a rift between the two groups because
there are oftentimes things where the
Green Lantern's just want to know what's
going on but the Guardians won't tell
them what it is that's happening this is
really significant with regards to
Kilowog and a lot of the members who are
part of the Green Lantern Corps when
these injured members of the lanterns
that would attack by Kyle Rayner land on
OA and when the question is asked what
happened and they say Kyle Rayner
basically lost his mind he attacked us
we don't know why the response of the
Guardians is no one is to intervene with
what's going on with Kyle Rayner you do
not offer him aid and you stay out of
his way you let him be now again this is
kind of crazy because it's basically you
know these members of the Green Lantern
Corps learning that one of their guys is
basically kind of going awry and seeming
to have some kind of crisis you know and
laying waste to innocent people out
there but the guardians are basically
saying you cannot intervene on his
behalf
you have to let him go so again this is
pretty tough it's really really hard for
any of the members of the Green Lantern
Corps to actually do on their own but
ultimately they're made to and again we
continue to see these experiences of
Kyle Rayner blacking out a Kyle Rayner
not knowing what's going on just kind of
waking up in the aftermath of all this
destruction and having no idea what's
happening now of course this will be
explained and we'll find out what it is
that's going on but while this is taking
place we actually have Kilowog sneaking
off a message to a member of the Green
Lantern Corps for the purpose of saying
hey look kind of winners basically lost
his mind
you have to go out and find him and you
have to bring him back now this again
also kind of shows us the solace that
goes on between the members of the Green
Lantern Corps in the sense that you know
cilok who basically speaks on behalf of
the Guardians and kind of upholds the
laws that they passed appears to Kilowog
kind of asking him what it is that you
were doing you know what's going on and
then ultimately says look if you hadn't
done it I would have now again this is
cool because it shows us the standing
that Kyle Rayner has among the Green
Lantern Corps remember going all the way
back to Emerald Twilight and so on and
so forth Hal Jordan is always viewed
with a slanted eye even if he's a good
guy now even if he's fighting on behalf
of the Green Lantern's even if he's
tried to repent for his actions under
the name of parallax he's still viewed
as someone that can't really be trusted
by the Green Lantern's but Kyle Rayner
does not hold that struggle Kyle Rayner
has always been there he's like the the
Dick Grayson of the Green Lantern Corps
he's this bright shining light that
everybody always trusts and so because
of that we end up finding out that in
the midst of him basically passing out
and going through one of his episodes
that Kyle Rayner basically stumbles upon
Mogo the Green Lantern planet now again
this is part of the guardians of the
universe plan but we don't know it yet
we simply know that mojo is there and
the cool thing about this is that Kyle
winter begins going through and having
these visions of various people that
he's had of course one of the first
major relationships that he had the girl
named Alex you know it's kind of cool
meeting with her because we get to sort
of go back and do this tour of Kyle
Waiters life the women that he's known
and the women that he's lost the
failures that he's had over the course
of its Green Lantern career you know
whether he meets Alex whether he meets
Donna Troy regardless of what person he
runs into is basically this ongoing
concept you know Jade the daughter of
Alan Scott the one who gave Kyle way
into the power of the star heart you
know all these different things come
together for this idea of Kyle
having his own doubts that for him he
does not view himself as a worthy Green
Lantern he views himself worthy in so
far that the other members of the Green
Lantern Corps trust him to a degree he
views himself worthy in so far that he's
allowed to wield the ring because he has
the willpower to do it if a ring is what
he needs to pull off the things that he
does but at the end of the day he does
not see himself as a worthy Green
Lantern he sees himself as a guy who's
made too many mistakes now this is cool
because what this does is it shows us
that the ghost of parallax still lingers
on the ghost of Hal Jordan losing his
mind wiping out the Green Lantern Corps
Kyle Rayner being the last remaining
Green Lantern it still lingers on it's
still very much a part of who he is and
what he's about and his biggest fear is
that he will become Hal Jordan his
biggest fear is that he will become
parallax somewhere along the line all
these losses that he's experienced all
these perceived failures that he's gone
through will come home to roost it's
really this idea that how Jordan had a
huge role in the life of Kyle Rayner and
the fact that Kaori is afraid of falling
down the same path now the reason why
this is so important it's because of the
fact the person we find out - Kilowog
was talking to is Hal Jordan himself and
so what's basically been happening is
Hal Jordan has been following this trail
of destruction by Kyle Rayner and
basically tracing him back to his own
particular location of course this again
brings us back to Kyle Rayner back on
the planet of Mogo and after facing off
against all these stress that he's had
facing off against major force for
example the guy who is responsible for
the death of Alex the guy who is
responsible for the death of Jayne for
these women who are important in the
life of Kyle Rayner facing against major
force is effectively Kyle Rayner facing
off against all the major issues and all
the struggles that he has now again
major force is not actually here Donna
Troy is not actually here Alex is not
actually here they are constructs
manifested by Mogo himself but it's
designed to force Kyle Rayner
to face himself he's basically facing
who he is everything that he's ever done
every mistake he's ever made in every
fear he ever has the reason why this is
important is because this covers the
emotional spectrum I mean think about it
fear rage hope death life all these
things represent the emotional spectrum
every single one he's basically proving
himself to be a master of he's
overcoming his fear he's overcome
the fact that sometimes people die and
there's nothing you can do to stop them
he's overcoming the idea that life has
its own pattern it has its own form you
know people are born and they die he's
facing his rage and his anger with major
force this is the first step that Kyle
winter takes to becoming the white
lantern so that's why this is so
important and so with Kyle made of
having a Green Lantern ring overcoming
all these things allows him to
effectively cast the ring aside and be a
power source unto himself and that's
really the test that the guardians of
the universe were forcing him to undergo
now of course the answer still has to be
asked why were these black ops taking
place why was Kyle Rayner effectively
losing his mind well of course what is
it happening here is we actually find
out there's - Kyle Rayner running around
here there's the Kyle Rayner on the
planet of Mogo and there's a Kyle Rayner
who's running around tearing things up
and ripping things apart now of course
Hal Jordan catches up to the to the bad
to the evil Kyle Rayner so to speak and
as the two of them end up doing battle
with one another don't we end up finding
out is the real Kyle Rayner actually
shows up and that's the crazy scenario
here because while Hal Jordan is talking
to this evil Kyle Rayner this evil Kyle
Rayner almost seems to be himself he's
talking about the terrible things he's
done trying to make up remorse trying to
do the right thing trying to be a good
person but ultimately lashes out and
begins attacking Hal Jordan and so with
the arrival of the good Kyle Rayner with
the arrival of the wheel Kyle Rayner
himself what we find out is that this
false Kyle laner is a guy named Alex
Niro now the reason why this matters is
because of the fact that with regards to
the Green Lantern landscape this is yet
another instance of Geoff Johns and Ron
Mars grabbing these different eras of
the Green Lantern mythos and sort of
rolling them all together and the reason
why I say this is because of the fact
that back when you know how Jordan was
the Green Lantern before he became
parallax a semester was always his main
villain you know Sinestro was Green
Lantern's Lex Luthor's so to speak but
when Hal Jordan was basically removed
from the DC landscape as the Green
Lantern and Kyle Rayner was put in his
place
DC needed to give Kyle later his own
arch-nemesis now of course this
eventually came in the form of major
force but Nero was really one of the one
of the attempts of DC to give Kyle
Rayner his own bad guy in the sense that
Nero was basically given a power ring by
the Corps diems those individuals in the
in the antimatter universe
who responsible for giving Sinestro his
first power ring and so the idea was to
kind of try to repeat the past only
updating it for the modern day the issue
is that it just didn't really work that
great it worked to a degree but it
didn't really work that great but again
this was basically in addition that was
added in the early 2000s 2001 or
something along those lines and so the
idea was that with Alexander Nero
somebody who was basically suffering
from mental disorder that he would be
the perfect nemesis against Kyle Rayner
and this is kind of a cool thing here
because in this battle that we see
between Hal Jordan and Kyle as well as
Nero Nero is just basically creating all
these yellow constructs these beer based
constructs now again this is kind of
hitting home at the original origin of
Nero but is also going into the idea
that the yellow Lantern Corps is growing
in number that the yellow Lantern Corps
is becoming something to worry about now
the Green Lantern's don't know this yet
they don't know that Sinestro is sending
rings out across the universe and
bolstering the ranks of his yellow
lantern corps you know all they know is
that this guy Nero shows up and this guy
is basically trying to confront people
as kyle rayner now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that what
Nero basically says is he was taken by
the court Ian this whole introduction
here he was taken by the court Ian and
he was basically forced to become Kyle
Rayner and basically discredit Kyle
Rayner as a Green Lantern hoping that it
would basically create a scenario where
Cowan would ultimately be taken down now
of course this was only one stage of the
operation the second stage was for Nero
to be captured and be taken to the
guardians of the universe and the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that after Nero is defeated by the
combined efforts of Kyle Rayner and Hal
Jordan and Nero is taken to the
guardians of the universe themselves
what we end up finding out here is that
what Carl Reiner says he wants answers
he wants to know what in the world is
going on here you know what it is the
guardians of the universe have been
doing and so on and so forth we find out
that Nero was basically a bomb that Nero
was designed to basically explode with
all this yellow lantern energy and wiped
out the guardians of the universe and
the process now before that happens we
do get answers in terms of what it is
that's going on and what we find out
here is the highway at all you know the
whole idea with Nero was not expected
instead Kyle Rayner was basically
supposed to meet with mojo and Moga was
supposed to basically you know force him
to endure all these different scenarios
meeting alex and donna troy and all the
things that we saw with him facing off
against his own fears in his own past
and so on and so forth and the reason
why
is because of the fact that this is
Geoff Johns and Ron Marz doing something
with Kyle Rayner this is why I said we'd
wait until around the end of the video
to cover all this when Kyle Rayner was
introduced as the Green Lantern as DC
began the progresses character they
reintroduced him as the character of ion
meaning that he had the power of the
Green Lantern and he had the power of
the star heart the problem with this was
that there was no real indication of
what this meant now of course we ended
up finding out they had an insane amount
of power and then he used almost all the
energy he had to basically recreate the
Green Lantern central power battery to
resurrect the guardians of the universe
and to restore the Green Lantern Corps
the reason why this matters is because
of the fact that following that his
power was basically moved away from him
being a god and back down to normal
levels but he was still being called ion
so the question had to be asked what
does that mean is he just is that just
the name he takes now I mean does it
have some kind of honorary measure
because there's no additional power to
go with it so what does it mean that
Kyle Rayner is ion and that was the idea
was to basically consolidate all those
different plot threads bring it together
and it's the guardians of the universe
basically saying Kyle Rayner is now the
torchbearer how later bears the legacy
of the Green Lantern Corps if for any
reason the Green Lantern Corps is
totally obliterated they're totally
wiped out the Guardians of the Universe
are killed the whole nine yards Kyle
Rayner is the only person who can
resurrect them from the dead he's the
only person that can bring them back and
so that's what the term torch bearer
means that he carries the mantle and the
legacy of the Green Lantern Corps and he
will restore them if anything ever
happens now what this also means is a
cow laner is the most important Green
Lantern because if Kyle wayna were to be
killed for example and in the Green
Lantern Corps were to be wiped out
there'd be nobody to bring them back
there'd be nobody to resurrect them they
would just sort of be gone forever and
that would really be about it but what
it does from here is it basically throws
Kyle Rayner into the fray and it makes
him a central focal point for Sinestro
because now what it means is that a
commoner is this important and if
calibrator is basically the torch bearer
for the Green Lantern's then now it is
let's go get Kyle Rayner we have to grab
him we have to corrupt him and swing him
to our side and that's one of the
coolest aspect of the other the whole
Sinestro Corps war is this like this
race for Kyle Rayner now of course after
this information is all dropped by the
guardians of the universe Miro begins to
detonate Nero begins to explode and
really almost you know wipes everybody
but of course cow waiter uses this
insane amount of power he has by
unlocking the full power of the star
heart as well as all the green lantern
energy he possesses and basically
confined all the energy of Nero back
down again but again this really kind of
brings kyle rayner back to having
someone that has an absurd amount of
power and it sets the stage for the idea
of Kyle Rayner being one of the sole
individuals out there who can resurrect
the green lantern for a person of such
incredible and extreme power that almost
nobody can stop him again setting the
stage for the idea of Kyle Rayner
becoming the white lantern but with that
being said guys if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later
[Music]